WATTERS, THIS IS "THE FIVE."
A MAJOR BREAKTHROUGH WITH NORTH
KOREA AFTER HISTORIC MEETING
INSIDE THE OVAL OFFICE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SAYING HE'LL
SIT DOWN WITH KIM JONG-UN IN
SINGAPORE.
>> President Trump: WE'LL BE
MEETING ON JUNE 12, IN
SINGAPORE.
I THINK IT'LL BE A PROCESS.
I NEVER SAID IT GOES IN ONE
MEETING.
I THINK IT WILL BE A PROCESS.
BUT THE RELATIONSHIPS ARE
BUILDING AND THAT'S POSITIVE.
WE TALKED ABOUT ENDING THE WAR.
THIS WAR HAS TO BE THE LONGEST
WAR, ALMOST 70 YEARS.
CAN YOU BELIEVE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ENDING OF THE KOREAN
WAR?
>> THE ANNOUNCEMENT COMING AFTER
TALKING WITH VICE CHAIRMAN KIM
YONG CHOI AFTER OVER AN HOUR.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SURPRISING SOME
WHEN ASKED ABOUT RECEIVING A
LETTER FROM KIM JONG-UN.
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN THE LETTER
YET.
I PURPOSELY DIDN'T OPEN THE
LETTER.
I HAVEN'T OPENED IT.
I DIDN'T OPEN IT IN FRONT OF THE
DIRECTOR.
I SAID WOULD YOU WANT ME TO OPEN
IT?
HE SAID YOU CAN READ IT LATER.
I MAY BE IN FOR A BIG SURPRISE,
FOLKS.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS SINCE READ
THE LETTER, I DON'T KNOW IF IT
WAS A BIG SURPRISE, BUT THAT
HAPPENED DURING THE DAILY
BRIEFING, MY FAVORITE PART, WHEN
HE MADE THAT JOKE.
AN AMAZING DAY, I THINK THAT THE
BIG NEWS KIMBERLY IS THAT, YES,
OF COURSE THE SUMMIT IS A GO, AT
LEAST TODAY, WE'LL SEE HOW THAT
GOES NEXT WEEK.
BUT ALSO, THE SOUTH KOREANS HAVE
BEEN PUSHING FOR THIS
POSSIBILITY OF SIGNING AN END TO
THE KOREAN WAR.
AND THE PRESIDENT INDICATING
THAT THAT IS LIKELY TO BE AN
OUTCOME OF THAT FIRST MEETING.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE FULL
deNUCLEARIZATION THAT HE WANTS,
BUT THAT IS ONE OF THE GO-TOS
FOR THE SOUTH KOREANS.
BY THE NORTH KOREANS AS WELL.
>> I THINK IS HISTORIC IN TERMS
OF WHAT HAS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED SO
FAR.
NO OTHER PRESIDENCY HAS BEEN
ABLE TO GET THE BALL SO FAR DOWN
IN THE COURT TO BE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
IN TERMS OF BROKERING A PEACE
AGREEMENT, DENUCLEARIZATION,
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS
SUMMIT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
INTERNATIONALLY.
IT BRINGS THE CHANCE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEACE AND
STABILITY IN THE REGION THAT'S
BEEN SO GEOPOLITICALLY FRAUGHT
WITH DANGER, THE REGIME.
WHAT WE SEE IS HE'S ABLE TO
BRING KIM JONG-UN TO THE TABLE
AND TO HIS KNEES, ESSENTIALLY.
HIS ECONOMY IS ON THE BRING OF
HE HAS REALLY NO CHOICE BUT TO
COME TO THE TABLE.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE
WITH TARIFFS, PUTTING PRESSURE,
APPLYING PRESSURE WITH THE
CHINESE, WHAT HE'S DONE IN TERMS
OF HIS OUTREACH AND RELATIONSHIP
WITH SOUTH KOREA AS WELL HAS ALL
PUT THIS INTO MOTION.
RELATIVELY QUICK PERIOD OF TIME
EARLY IN HIS PRESIDENCY.
I THINK IT'S MOST YOU A SPACIOUS
AND FAVORABLE FOR THE UNITED
STATES AND FOR NORTH AND SOUTH
KOREA.
>> YOU MEANT SANCTIONS NOT
TARIFFS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE HAD OVER.
00 ADDITIONAL SANCTIONS THAT HE
WAS READY TO PUT ON.
AND THE NORTH KOREANS KNEW ABOUT
THAT, IN THE MEETING THE
PRESIDENT SAID, OKAY, I WON'T DO
IT.
AT LEAST NOT AT THIS MOMENT.
>> IF HE DOESN'T LIKE WHAT HE
SEE WHEN IS HE OPENS THE LETTER,
SLAP A FEW MORE SANCTIONS BACK
ON.
I WAS DOWNSTAIRS EARLIER AND
THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE MSNBC
CHANNEL, ON IT'S RIGHT UNDER
ROCK CENTER, I WAS FORCED TO
WATCH THEM COVER THIS --
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN
THIS.
WE WON'T JUDGE YOU.
>> I THOUGHT I NEEDED TO MAKE IT
CLEAR.
[LAUGHING]
I WASN'T WATCHING IT ON PURPOSE.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT BRINGING,
LIKE KIMBERLY SAID, THE TWO
SIDES TOGETHER AND ENDING A WAR
THAT'S GONE ON.
WE'RE STILL AT WAR, TECHNICALLY,
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
DECADES.
AND THE ANCHORS COME OUT AND
THEY CRITICIZE HIM --
>> REALLY?
>> I SAW THAT.
>> GOING BACK AND FORTH ON THE
SINGAPORE SUM INTEREST FOR
CANCELLING IT, GOING BACK, ON
THEN SAYING WHAT A HYPOCRITE, HE
GETS OUT OF THE IRAN DEAL, THEN
WANTS TO MAKE A DEAL WITH NORTH
KOREA.
I'M THINKING TO MYSELF, IF THIS
WAS PRESIDENT OBAMA, AND THIS
WAS GOING ALONG THE WAY IT'S
GOING ALONG UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP, HE WOULD BE HAILED.
>> NO KIDDING.
>> THE GUY IN THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY, IT'S AMAZING THEY WOULD
BRING A GUY WHO RESPONSIBLE FOR
HACKING SONY, HACKING ON
PEOPLE'S LIMBS, DOING SOME OF
THE MOST ATROCIOUS THINGS TO
HUMAN BEINGS IN THE WORLD, ONE
OF THE MOST BRUTAL PEEP AIM
ROUND, INTO THE WHITE HOUSE,
INTO THE OVAL OFFICE, NOT JUST
FOR HANDING OFF.
LETTER BUT THEN TO SIT AND
DISCUSS THINGS, BUT THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE FORCED TO DEAL WITH
SAVAGE PEOPLE IN THIS WORLD,
SAYS A LOT ABOUT OUR COUNTRY AND
WHAT WE'RE WILLING TO DO IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE PEACE.
CHINA IS AS YOU'VE BEEN SAYING,
PRETTY INTEGRAL IN THIS.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO
SEE NORTH KOREA deFANGED.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT A CRISIS
WITH MIGRANTS FLOWING ACROSS.
AND LET'S JUST SAY KOREA COMES
TOGETHER AS ONE, EVENTUALLY A
POWERHOUSE, THEN JAPAN RIGHT
THERE.
AND THEIR ALLIANCE WITH THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU HAVE A PRETTY BOLD KIND OF
WESTERN ORIENTED ALLIANCE, RIGHT
ON CHINA'S DOORSTEP.
THEY MIGHT NOT LIKE THAT.
WE'LL JUST CONTINUE TO SEE HOW
CHINA REACTS.
.
THE PRESIDENT SAID, MY FAVORITE
LINE, WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS, HE
WENT A LITTLE BIT MORE EMPHATIC
WILL NOT BE THE ONLY MEETING,
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE WHERE
YOU FINISH THE WHOLE DEAL.
THE OTHER THING, HE DID, I DON'T
KNOW IF WE HAVE THE VIDEO, IF
YOU CAN PULL IT UP, HE NOT ONLY
DID HE HAVE AN HOUR-LONG MEETING
BUT HE DID A PERSONAL DIPLOMACY
AND WALKED THEM TO THEIR CARS.
A HUGE SIGN OF RESPECT.
HE TOOK THAT, LIKE SORT OF GROUP
PICTURE THAT THEY COULD BE
SHOWING BACK IN NORTH KOREA.
>> WELL, TWO POINTS.
ONE, HE KEPT SAYING AGAIN AND
AGAIN IT'S PROCESS.
THIS IS ALWAYS A PROCESS.
IS A DEVELOPER FROM QUEENS NOT A
PROFESSOR FROM COLUMBIA.
HE DOES THINGS LIKE A DEVELOPER
FROM QUEENS.
MEANING, IT'S ABOUT RESPECT AND
RECIPROCITY, SERVICING A
CLIENTD.
SO -- A CLIENT.
YOU KAEFL RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR
CLIENT, YOU MAKE THEM FEEL GOOD,
YOU WAVE THE CARROT, YOU GOT THE
STICK BUT YOU WAVE THE CARROT.
THE TONE HAS TO REFLECT WIN-WIN.
IT'S LIKE YOU AND YOU I ARE BOTH
GOING TO GET SOMETHING OUT OF
THIS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE CRITICAL,
YOU'RE DOING A WIN HIVE WIN WITH
A HEARTLESS KILLER.
HE'S A DEVELOPER FROM QUEENS,
HE'S DEALT WITH WORSE.
[LAUGHING]
THE OMGSS THAT YOU HAVE, OKAY,
YOU GOT TO MEET WITH DR. EVIL
BUT THE OTHER OPTION IF YOU
DON'T, THAT MEANS WAR OR
STARVATION F YOU'RE AGAINST THIS
MEETING, THEN ARE YOU SAYING
MAYBE WE STARVE THESE PEOPLE TO
DEATH, 25 MILLION PEOPLE THROUGH
SANCTIONS AND WHAT NOT.
IF YOU ACTUALLY TRY SOMETHING
NEW.
THAT'S WHY THIS IS A
BREAKTHROUGH, WAS YOU HAVE A
DEVELOPER FROM QUEENS WHO SAID
WHY NOT.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
AND EVERYBODY WHO IS FREAKING
OUT ABOUT THAT MIGHT WANT TO
WAIT AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
CRITICISM TODAY.
ESPECIALLY TODAY OF ALL DAYS
WHERE IT WAS ALL OF THE
DIPLOMACY IN ONE, BUT, GERALDO,
YOU HAVE A PERSPECTIVE FROM
HAVING KWOVERD THE CONFLICT IN
KOREA OVER THE YEARS AND YOU
SAID WERE YOU THERE IN --
>> IN THE '80s, A COUPLE OF
TIMES.
TO JESSE'S POINT, YOU MAKE PEACE
WITH YOUR ENEMIES, YOU DON'T
MAKE PEACE WITH YOUR FRIENDS.
YOU HOLD YOUR NOSE AND YOU GO IN
THERE AND YOU KNOW, PLENTY OF,
IN WAR TIME, PLENTY OF, YOU
KNOW, CRIMINAL ALLEGATIONS TO GO
AROUND.
BUT WATCHING DANA'S EXCELLENT
PROGRAM AT 2:00, THAT LINE
REALLY STUCK IN MY HEAD, CAN YOU
BELIEVE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ENDING THE KOREAN WAR.
CAN YOU BELIEVE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ENDING THE KOREAN WAR.
deNUCLEARIZATION, ALL OF THIS,
THE NUANCE --
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE IN AMERICA,
IT'S BEEN A PART OF THAT.
SERVED IN KOREA, BEEN AT THE
DMZ, I MEAN --
>> VIRTUALLY EVERYONE.
>> SEVERAL GENERATIONS OF
AMERICANS.
>> WHAT IF THEY UNITE --
>> THEY WON'T.
>> I WAS SAYING, ARE SAYING WHAT
A GREAT THING IT IS TO TALK B
BUT SAY IT WON'T HAPPEN.
>> TALK ABOUT UNIFICATION, I'M
TALKING ABOUT A PEACE TREATY
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES, THE
UNITED NATIONS.
>> DON'T GO NUCLEAR.
I DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING.
WHERE IS THE EXAMPLE OF THAT
TODAY.
THE SIN TRIF GAL FORCE KEEPS
COMPANIES SEPARATE.
>> THEY'RE UNITED, THEIR
ECONOMIES MIGHT BE MUCH MORE IN
SYNC.
SECTARIAN DICTATORSHIP, PEOPLE
GET CELL PHONES, AS THEY GET THE
SATELLITE TV, I THINK IT WILL
HAVE A MODIFYING EFFECT ON THE
COUNTRY.
BUT, I MEAN, TO ME RECORD LOW,
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR BLACK PEOPLE
FOR HISPANIC, WOMEN.
THIS IS THE BEST DAY OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
>> THE WAY HE APPLIES PRESSURE
ACROSS ALL DIFFERENT FRONTS.
TO BE ABLE TO GET THEM TO COME
TO THE TABLE TO SUPPORT IT.
THEY SUPPORT THE NORTH KOREAN
REGIME.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN MOTIVATED.
THEY ARE ON THEIR KNEES,
STARVATION NATION, AND KIM LAST
YEAR MADE A PROMISE TO HIS
PEOPLE AND SAID WE'RE GOING TO
BRING YOU OUT OF THE DESPICABLE
HOLE YOU'RE IN.
I PROMISE GROWTH, BETTER
LIFESTYLE, STANDARD OF LIVING.
HE HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO DELIVER.
SINCE HE MADE THAT PROM WIS THE
SANCTIONS, THINGS OF GOTTEN
WORSE.
HE IS DIEING TO BRING HIS
COUNTRY INTO THE 21st CENTURY.
HE SEES THE PATHWAY FORWARD WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HOPEFULLY
THEY CAN WORK OUT A SYSTEM WHERE
THEY CAN HAVE THE SANCTIONS
EASED OFF, WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME WE TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
HOW THEY RAMP DOWN.
>>nd HE TOLD THE PRESS TO PACK
THEIR BAGS, THEY'RE GOING TO
SINGAPORE.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY --
>> NOBEL PEACE PRIZE?
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY YOU CAN
START BY SURPLUS FOOD AS A
GESTURE OF GOODWILL.
>> ALSO INFORMATION.
>> ONE WEEK SUPPLY OF GRAIN.
>> INFORMATION AND INTERNET
ACCESS.
>> BUT ALSO YOU HAVE TO STOP
SAYING THEY'RE ON THEIR KNEES.
BECAUSE THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS,
IS PRIDE AND RESPECT.
AND WHEN YOU SERVICE A CLIENTD
YOU DON'T SAY WE'VE GOT THEM
WHERE WE WANT THEM.
>> THAT'S WHY HE WALKED THEM TO
THE CAR, DID THE GENEROUS --
>> VERY RESPECTFUL.
>> A SUBTLE SHIFT THAT A
SALESMAN KNOWS, GET THEM INSIDE.